I truly don't know if I could have come
up with a more perfect guess for the
first episode of the show Sam Harris is
a neuroscientist author and founder of
project reason and according to some
people he's also a genocide Ulm a niak
bent on nuking much of the Middle East
Sam welcome to the show thank you it's a
pleasure to be here which which half of
that would you say describes you better
we'll talk about both halves I imagine
yeah I'll take the first though well I'm
truly thrilled that you're here and that
you know you came in for my first show
you said you were gonna come in in
October when your book comes out but I I
twisted your arm sufficiently and and
here yeah well congratulations on the
show - thanks I appreciate it all right
so let's start I want to start basically
we're sort of I really found out about
you and where I think this whole
discussion that we've every everyone's
been having for the last eight months or
so started and you were on Real Time
with Bill Maher and you were on to talk
about your book Bill was talking about
liberalism and Islam and Ben Affleck was
on and I know everyone's seen this clip
already but let's take a look when you
want to talk about the treatment of
women and homosexuals and free thinkers
and and public intellectuals in the
Muslim world I would argue that liberals
have failed us and the crucial point of
confusion yeah thank you well I mean the
crucial point of confusion is that that
we have been sold this meme of
Islamophobia where every criticism of
the doctrine of Islam gets conflated
with bigotry toward Muslims as people
right that is it's intellectually
ridiculous even it gets you the person
who understands the officially codified
doctrine of Islam oh say what this is I
think I'm actually well educated on this
time I'm asking you so you're saying if
I criticize that you're saying that
Islamophobia is not a real thing that if
you're critical of something it's not a
real thing when we do it right it's
really I'm not denying that
certain people are bigoted against
Muslims as people right and that's a
problem big of you but the why don't we
it's gross it's racist it's not it's but
it's soni so it's like saying go donate
your shifty Jew
you're not lab salutely not we are say
you guys are saying if you want to be
liberals believe in liberal principles
like freedom speech like my
we are endowed by our forefathers in a
little bowl a strike all men are created
oh man we have to be able to criticize
bad ideas so first off I think it's
gross it's races should be your Twitter
bio
have you considered putting it very
people have been just throwing that at
me on Twitter ever since yes yeah it's a
bit of a meme yeah so what I want to
start with is because I think there's
obviously a ton we can talk about the
fallout of this and we'll get to that
but I want to talk about actually the
specifics of what happened there right
did you expect because usually when they
bring on the guest that sits on bills
side of the table usually it's for a
one-on-one with bill and sort of a
casual conversation the panel doesn't
really jump in did you expect that whole
thing to explode the way that it did no
no not at all I was selling a book on
meditation at that moment I was talking
and the first that's about 60 seconds
into the exchange yeah and so initially
it starts with you know how can an
atheist be spiritual and that was were
talking along those lines and I said
something slightly derogatory about the
New Age and Ben jumped into that space
and and was at my throat about Islam
hadn't even come up so he clearly was
poised to do that and yeah it's that
it's considered a protected interview
everyone on the panel knows they're not
supposed to jump in what do you think
was going on with Ben well apart from
him possibly being on steroids for his
his Batman role I don't know I just
think he clearly had heat I think he had
no idea who I was really but someone had
given him a paragraph a bio of me and
had more or less told him that you know
I'm a hey bigots who's intolerant of
Muslims and you know he really should
you know take a whack at me on that
topic yeah I'm so case like and honestly
I was I think I was a little slow to
appreciate how hostile he was because I
wasn't just looking at him I was
actually looking at Nick Kristof who I
have actually collided with on this
topic and and who my remarks were more
pitched to I think more appropriately
pitch to because Nick really deals with
with especially women's rights issues in
the developing world to to a unique
degree so I had a bit of a bone to pick
with Nick and and the brothers you know
of Michael Steele was on the panel and
so my attention was split and so I
wasn't
just kind of at the corner of my
consciousness was I was understanding
that there was a level of hostility here
that I didn't really expect or know how
to interpret yeah so talking about
knowing how to interpret it like it's a
little different if Nick Kristof or some
author or a philosopher had immediately
jumped out at you like that I think
perhaps would have dealt with it in one
way but when a big hot I mean this is an
a-list Hollywood star this is Batman
jumps at you that way did that throw you
off in a way I mean not you look you
were cool and collected there but did
just having to deal with someone at that
level it's like a different ballgame you
know yeah well you're it's hard to
interrupt a movie star who doesn't want
to be interrupted so at a certain point
you know if bills not going to cut him
off I can't cut him off so trying to get
a word in edgewise is a challenge there
but I mean the irony is the sentence he
was reacting to the sentence where I say
everyone conflates criticism of Islam a
set of ideas with bigotry against
Muslims as people he no sooner no sooner
were those words uttered than he
demonstrated my thesis yeah every
subsequent statement and it was just
impossible to to get to get that mirror
bent you know close enough toward his
face so that he could recognize what
what he was doing right so he literally
for the remainder of the 12 minutes I
mean he continually and repeatedly
proved your theory then I continued for
an hour in the greenroom afterwards and
it was it was by no means resolved yeah
and clearly hasn't been resolved since
all right so I I don't want to focus too
much on that specifically but I just
want to talk about when someone throws
you know he throws this it's gross it's
racist suddenly I noticed that the next
day the onus was on you and Bill Maher
and a little more to Bill I think to
prove that you weren't racist right I
have never I've been a big fan of Bill's
for a long time I've never heard anyone
call him racist ever before but suddenly
the next day on all the websites it was
Ben Affleck calls Sam Harris and Bill
Maher races is Ben app is Bill Maher
races is Sam Harris racist how does that
feel in that moment of the discussion
when someone throws that gauntlet down
because you're yours you're used to
debating people with ideas just words
well it's very dispiriting because
it's almost guaranteed to convince half
the audience if it's a and I miss
something this is the first thing I said
to Ben afterwards in the green room I
said do you realize just calling us
racist convinced half the people
listening and watching that we're racist
and these are using that word is enough
for people so and people just assume
where there's smoke there's fire they
can't figure out what anyone is actually
saying their attention span is so
truncated that using words like that
again just convinces fully half the
audience and and and the most depressing
thing in the aftermath of this was to
see the outpouring the celebration of
you know disproportionally in the Muslim
community on social media from people
who thought that he had just mopped the
floor with us that he had exposed our
racism for all to see and he had argued
brilliantly and he's just this white
knight for the Muslim world and it was
so embarrassing because he of course he
did none of they wasn't making any sense
he wasn't listening to what we were
actually saying and he was simply you
know calling us names yeah no very
loaded names and and it works for people
who want to perceive the conversation
along those lines was there was this
meme or this idea of you as a racist was
that even out there cuz now I see it at
a dialogue all the time but but I had
never heard of it and to be a hundred
percent honest with you I had sort of
ancillary knew your work I'm not even
sure if I was following you on Twitter
at the time so I know a lot of people
when they're done with this their group
is just a Sam Harris fanboy and blah
blah blah but I really I didn't I was
watching that and I thought well here's
someone making some sense and now Ben
Affleck's just using the worst kind of
language with him but was that idea
about you out there before well not well
yeah I think Glenn Greenwald and a few
other people had put it out there so it
was I mean it's it's a trope of
political politically correct liberal
apology around criticism of Islam so
even this notion of Islamophobia the
idea that that to single out Islam for
any special attention as a set
of doctrines there's a political reality
in today's world is a tantamount to
synonymous with or covertly motivated by
racist bigotry toward Arabs or brown
skinned people and and you know there
are many people like Glenn Greenwald who
quite irresponsibly you know make that
point again and again and so yeah so
Ben's sort of that was not the first
time criticism of Islam has been
conflated with racism but it's it's I
mean it's it's such a crazy claim
because I mean this has been pointed out
again and again and Bill's done this but
Islam is not a race you know it's a set
of ideas you can't convert away from a
race you can't convert to arrays really
eventual Dolezal you can give this right
you yes you can you can a few one person
can do that everything I say about Islam
applies to white converts to the faith
every bit as much as it does to Arabs or
anyone born into it sure in fact even
more so because that may you had if
you're thirty years old and and not have
this drummed into you on Mother's knee
and with a full adult you know clear
viewing of your life and all the
opportunities available to you you
decide to convert to the most
doctrinaire and repressive form of Islam
well then then I have the most to say
about you you know someone like you know
Adam Gadahn who's the you know the I
think he's now dead but the this guy
from Orange County who joined al-qaeda
you know this is these are so and
everything I say about Islam as a
religion that you know is it's true I've
said some disparaging things about it as
a set of ideas and I've compared it
unfavorably to Buddhism and Hinduism
which you know they're their adherents
are for the most part not quite like me
so the idea that racism has the notions
of race has anything to do with this is
just completely crazy
[Music]